no international flights are being
allowed to land for a week
in vietnam's capital hanoi the
announcement on tuesday follows a
similar ban by ho chi minh city a few
days ago
infections in vietnam remained low for
most of last year
but have risen since late april taiwan
once lauded for its success in
containing the virus
saw clusters emerge once it relaxed its
pandemic restrictions
when you're very successful you are not
forced to improve
only when you fear then are you forced
to improve
we were too successful in the past year
in malaysia a two-week lockdown
beginning on tuesday
means only essential services and
businesses
are allowed to operate health officials
here say
the surge in cases is caused by more
infectious variants
and people breaching pandemic
restrictions to celebrate the muslim
festival of eid
last month malaysia has recorded nearly
2
800 deaths from covet 19. 40
of those were in may alone
vaccination rates in asia remain low on
average
only six percent of the population has
received at least
one vaccine dose experts say
containment of the virus must therefore
be prioritized
for now we have to be vigilant we have
to be doing good surveillance
we have to as communities we have to
come together and accept
um movement restriction uh border
controls
um the use of personal protective
equipment masks etc and practicing good
hygiene
um this we will be stuck with this until
until we get high high coverage with
vaccines and that's the only way out
many countries are now ramping up their
vaccination campaigns
japan is hoping to vaccinate one third
of its population before it hosts
the summer olympics in july and vietnam
says
it's seeking to buy vaccine production
technology
while also pushing to acquire more doses
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur
dr abhishek grimal is the asia pacific
emergency health coordinator for the
international federation
of red cross and red crescent societies
he says the presence of new variants
could be contributing to the rising
cases
these countries have done very well
during the first weight
wave of the kovit but like since we are
already
more than a year into this pandemic many
people
are are a bit sick and tired of
following all the rules and regulation
and wants to go back
to the normal life on top of that these
countries also are seeing now the
variance of concern
which is much more transmissible and
infectious
than the previous or the original
strains of sars
fighters too like losing or lowering our
guard again against the virus plus
the presence of variance of concerns can
be attributed
as two major cause of spike of cases in
southeast asia
so more studies need to be done to
really see like whether or not
like the new variant which appear to be
the combination of
two variants of concern already one is
b117 that was first detected in uk
and the b1617 which was first detected
in
india it appears it is a combination of
that
and some of the local experts in vietnam
believes it is highly transmissible
than any of these strain and it is
really an alarming
sign not only for vietnam but also for
for the other states around our other
countries around vietnam
as if if this is true then we are
looking for
a major rise of government 19 in the
region but
stating that we need to have more
assessment to understand
the impact of the concern on the total
case rise